from the ali frasier fight by six make
it four everybody out
serial killers
froot loops lies jesus
that's what sells magazines bob you
should lose all those corny war photos
out there what have you got for me i
don't have time for a cocktail hour sip
and grill i want you to speak at the
opening of my exhibition
just want you to say something about how
great i was was yeah oh great i was i
mean how great is the lamb of course
but you know way back then when you
could be great when the truth still
meant something so yeah you just have to
say that
i'm the
greatest photographer that life magazine
has ever had but you are you're the
single most impossible photographer that
life has ever had well [ __ ] it did you
say that then i can't get i told you
when you called i'm i'm out of town that
week i got a board meeting look bob i'm
done
i'm tired my body's older than i am
i'm always in goddamn pain i can't trust
my feet anymore
constantly a foul mood
even the drugs bore me my kids won't
speak to me
you know i could go head first
into a shrimp cocktail at any given
moment
and i'm broke
i'm sorry gene i wasn't looking for your
sympathy i was just stating the facts
by the way
if anyone should be asking for sympathy
bob
it should be you
look at this dracu churning out amazing
no ladder and you got all the way up on
your high horse just like that
we practically give this magazine away
to our readers we cover all the major
issues that touch their lives issues
from all over the country all around the
world we do it every week on top of that
we fight television sets for the same
eyeballs you took for granted would
always be there it gets worse all the
time what we do what i do every day is
find a way to pay for all of this and
keep it going what we put on a cup what
we put in the middle of those stores
that's what does that
wow
well your horse is obviously much higher
than mine